I recently looked into toxic ingredients
found in makeup which got me thinking
what other products do I use on a daily
basis have chemicals that might be bad
for my health so I decided to take a
closer look at my home and what I found
out pretty bad we spend around a third
of our lives in bed but what are we
really breathing in during our beauty
rest a common ingredient in mattresses
is flame retardants in the 70s
regulators push to make furniture safer
by treating mattresses with these
chemicals that are supposed to delay a
fire from spreading the intent was to
protect consumers but research suggests
these chemicals can cause thyroid
problems learning disabilities and
hormone disruption don't think you can
just wash all that off chemical flame
retardants accumulate in your body over
time if you're like me you want your
bathroom smelling rosy
but that scented candle air freshener
and even your body wash shampoo lotion
and perfume likely contain harmful
chemicals salads have been linked to
lower sperm count changes in estrogen
levels and infertility and genital
defects in babies and phthalates aren't
the only chemical that alter hormones so
does BPA a chemical found in the
majority of cans in the u.s. it's used
to prevent bacteria from getting into
food and to keep metal from corroding
low dose long-term exposure is
associated with lots of health problems
including cancer you may have heard that
nonstick pans are potentially toxic but
the family of chemicals that keeps
things from sticking are in more than
just cookware they're also in some
microwave popcorn bags and pizza boxes
these chemicals called pfcs can mess
with reproduction and hormones stain
resistant carpet can contain pfcs
these chemicals can get into your system
by breathing them in or absorbing them
through your skin remember flame
retardants well there in your living
room too they've been added to couches
pillows carpets even TVs and electronics
so you might be wondering doesn't the
government regulate this kind of thing
it all goes back to a law passed in 1976
which doesn't require companies to test
chemicals before releasing them into the
market the law hasn't changed in 40
years and that means that out of the
80,000 chemicals that are out there in
the
market the majority of them haven't been
tested I spoke with Avery Lindemann from
the green science Policy Institute about
what this means for us unfortunately the
way the laws in the US are written we
cannot as consumers assume that the
government is making sure that products
are safe and that the chemicals and
products are safe and so unfortunately
consumers do have to do their own
research while the EPA is responsible
for keeping us safe from harmful
chemicals the relatively weak compared
to the deep pockets and powerful
lobbying efforts of the chemical
industry as consumers we need to
pressure companies to not use harmful
chemicals in their products but at the
end of the day shouldn't the government
be responsible for making sure that what
we're buying is safe